you've been doing a lot of battling too
lately
yeah yeah I'm back man I'm back in the
in the ring in my bag it got me feeling
young again you know that's how I
started doing music battling being
competitive so it's helping me get back
to my roots I was gonna say for you is
it like you've had such a long journey
through music
um
do you do you feel like because I feel
like when when people see some of these
lineups right and I was just talking to
uh Ness about this like I'm like like
the battle rap world is such a like
Niche hip-hop space that like people can
be like real hardcore hip-hop heads and
really not be super tapped into what's
going on in the battle world you know
what I'm saying of course it's his own
it's his own Universe man right you know
man and you're like a name to where if
you're on the flyer like anybody's like
oh that's Cassidy you know what I'm
saying like you're bringing eyes to that
world that maybe not would have checked
it out otherwise you know what I'm
saying so you find it easy for you to
thrive in that space in terms of like
because you're bringing like you're kind
of bringing a lot of eyes to it so I'm
sure you could charge more than most
people
yeah like that lane that former battle
rap I started it like nobody never
really seen that form of battle rap
before they seen me in the freeway
battle we made a legendary you might
have heard about it especially if you
wasn't really in the industry and super
connected you might have heard about it
but you never actually got a chance to
see it especially on camera right so
that was the first time people got a
chance to see like somebody face to face
being competitive snap into no beat and
like to no real flow like just talking
to each other that was the first time
people really got to see it so that's
that paved the way to all of these
leagues starting so I felt like I
started all of this right and um I
inspired like
um
99.9 percent of the people that do it to
do it if not a hundred percent so that's
the reason why I feel like I deserve the
money I run things and when I come back
I shake it up and that's why that part
of the culture respond like they do when
I'm back because they know the work I
put in yeah yo the neither you battle
freeway give me the background of that
night because was it he they were on Hot
97 that night or something yeah earlier
that night yeah and then Swiss was like
I got because obviously freeway's from
Philly you're from Philly so that
happened at a recording studio
yeah so did you pull up knowing y'all
were gonna battle
and did he know you guys were gonna
battle
no I was already in the studio and I
went to McDonald's when I heard them on
the radio rapping and talking about they
want to battle and
anybody could get it so they wasn't
talking about me but I felt like they
was right so when I got back to the
studio
um I told Swiss about it and he like I
don't matter
Jay-Z coming to a studio tonight anyway
so I'm just sitting around doing Jay-Z
got there he introduced them to me
introduced me as like
him like the next one yeah and Jay-Z
took offense today like what you ain't
had my artist I got the hottest [__]
and that's how I started getting
competitive Who start talking he called
them up we called out peoples up next
thing you know the studio was crowded
and we battled oh man that was a
legendary moment man yeah
um I had heard that you guys were
supposed to run it back it just didn't
end up getting worked out
yeah it was supposed to be with the URL
with smack we were supposed to do
another one but I don't know
business-wise it ain't just didn't line
up yeah that's fair yeah that was a I
feel like that because correct me if I'm
wrong but that came out did that video
come out like right away or was it like
later on that we actually saw the video
hmm nah it took some time at first
at first it was um
it was on audio like a DJ got a copy of
the tape and put it on audio so a lot of
people only they just had it on Napster
movie was like download battles off
Napster I think it was even before that
time because it was on VHS team so the
DJ put it on you know CD on mixtape and
that's how people started to hear it
around you know around the world they
was hearing the audio but didn't see the
visual and
um
it was floating around in the industry
certain key people got a chance to see
the visual but the internet wasn't out
it was like it was like some Word of
Mouth [__] like yo I saw this tape that
that [__] don't exist I know I saw it
yeah exactly and it was no YouTube no
internet for people to really get access
to it so
it was just like big on the streets and
building up for a long period of time
and then when YouTube and the internet
dropped and everything then they
re-uploaded it and people started
getting to see it all around the world
yeah no legendary man